she's a pediatrician a billionaire
philanthropist a mother and the wife of
Facebook founder and CEO Mark Zuckerberg
chan and her husband have pledged 99% of
their Facebook shares to what's called
the Chan Zuckerberg initiative he is one
of the most well funded philanthropic
organizations in the world and only on
CBS this morning we met chan at an
Oklahoma prison where an innovative
program is trying to break the cycle of
mass incarceration we're gonna have more
of that story for you tomorrow but first
let's take a look at how she went from
the child of refugees to a philanthropic
game changer you don't do a lot of
interviews no why is that I would rather
be doing the work and then the heart of
it I'm a practitioner I've worked in the
classroom I've worked in the clinic and
that's where I get the inspiration and
the nurturing for my soul that I need as
well as being able to see and stay
connected to what we need to keep our
eye on in order to build a better future
a better future is exactly what her
Chinese Vietnamese parents and
grandparents were chasing when they came
to the United States in the 1970s as
refugees my grandparents did something I
think is completely courageous they put
their kids on a boat and watch that boat
drift off to sea we know very firsthand
that hardship is real and opportunities
are available but not available to
everyone but those opportunities lead
Priscilla Chan to Harvard University on
a full scholarship at first it felt like
an alien world you almost left Harvard
yeah I had my transfer paperwork done so
when was that lightbulb moment like I am
kind of the epitome of the American
dream and I do need to stay here at
Harvard I think I immediately knew when
I showed up on campus that's something
out of this world had happened and but I
wanted to give up but I
I also found a home running an
after-school program and when I saw what
those kids faced in challenges far
beyond what I faced and I saw what
needed to be done
I knew Hyatt to stay and then what year
did you meet Mark Zuckerberg I met mark
four weeks into college so you were
gonna leave even though you had met him
yeah he just had a totally different
mentality in terms of being able to do
things and take Grist the night and I
thought he was fascinating but he was 18
I didn't think I was gonna marry him
they eventually did marry in 2012 and
now have two daughters and a Hungarian
sheepdog that has become an internet
sensation how did you end up with beasts
oh boy I didn't know better I didn't
have a dog growing up do you ever think
you would go from being a child of
refugees to Harvard pediatrician and now
billionaire philanthropist even before I
had met mark I knew it I had received
more than I could have ever imagined and
it was going to be my life's work to
make sure that that was true for others
you're getting a little teary-eyed yeah
it means a lot to me
it's not enough to just connect people
we have to make sure that those
connections are positive 2018 proved to
be the most challenging year yet for
Facebook the social media giant is
facing a multi-billion dollar fine for a
series of privacy scandals including a
massive data breach has it been a tough
year in your house you know we've done a
lot of work in thinking about how we
should be operating and Mark and his
team has done a great job at Facebook
but for the Chan Zuckerberg initiative
we also want to make sure that we are
making good choices and being good
stewards of the opportunity and so it's
an accelerator for us to really think
there were some of the harder problems
does the initiative and all the good
work that it does is that a way to
whitewash some of the problems that
Facebook has had especially in 2018 we
have always known that we were going to
give back
and we launched formerly the Chan
Zuckerberg initiative in 2015 this is
not a 2018 project we were going to be
doing this for decades and frankly there
are a lot easier ways to build up PR
than trying to tackle education reform
or criminal justice reform the
initiatives goals are ambitious tackling
global health and trying to cure and end
all diseases by the end of the century
you want to eliminate all disease yeah
well if you think about it penicillin
didn't exist 80 years ago it's not
linear the microscope changed the world
our ability to sequence DNA changed the
world we are not the ones doing it we
are empowering scientists to actually be
on the forefront and making those
discoveries what you think will
ultimately have a greater impact on
society Facebook or the initiative do
you soon to say I hope that Chan
Zuckerberg initiative is able to achieve
its goals but we have ambitious goals
and so if we can cure prevent and manage
all disease I think they'll be
astounding in itself
do you have political ambitions no no I
don't even want to sit here to talk to
you thank you does mark have political
ambitions no not for our family you
don't think he'll ever run for office
the reason I ask because these are in
some ways initiatives that impact the
public policy debate and at some point
you start getting deeply enough involved
in it that you start saying I can only
do so much with my money I have to
change the laws we believe in advocacy
but we don't believe that we're the
right person people in our experience
and voice should not be the most
powerful in the room what is your family
think of the work you're doing now you
know it's funny my mom is still like are
you a real doctor yet and do you still
work as a doctor but they are incredibly
proud and it
sited about the work that we're doing
yeah my mom's mainly just really proud
yeah yeah you can appreciate that as it
as you know as a daughter of immigrants
ya know no matter how much money that
you have or whatever it's like are you a
doctor
parents always have such a unique
perspective of putting things and
putting things in perspective about how
they see their children but clearly her
mom is proud and what that worked that
she and Mark are doing is also extremely
important and you're so right about the
American story of a refugee and then
yeah I mean from being a refugee child
to giving back the way they are that is
you know the the epitome of the American
story yeah both of them yeah she's very
very impressive very very impressive I
do want to note too that we sat down
with Priscilla Chan before yesterday's
report from the British Parliament which
branded facebook as digital gangsters
now they are accusing the social media
giant of deliberately misleading the
investigation into disinformation and
the quote extent of Russian interference
in foreign relations elections rather a
facebook spokesperson told CBS News that
the company shares the committee's
concerns about false news and election
integrity adding that it is open to
meaningful regulation and it has already
made substantial changes now as
Priscilla said to us Facebook and the
Chan Zuckerberg initiative she says they
are two separate things but nevertheless
Mark Zuckerberg is the co-founder is the
CEO of Facebook so it certainly comes up
and and the initiatives there are
funding Falls and Rises as do shares of
Facebook too it was nice to hear how
she's thinking in the work that they're
doing more because you're right you're
very you very seldom get her her
perspective on things and guess what
she's a very smart cookie and guess the
gal who knows don't have more for you oh
okay it'll be tomorrow as we mentioned
we're gonna continue our conversation
with Priscilla Chan and she's gonna take
us inside a women's prison in Oklahoma
to show us an innovative program that is
trying to break the cycle of mass
incarceration I did want to meet
Priscilla Chan I've been trying to get
this interview for a long time I've also
always wanted to go inside a prison yeah
Oklahoma has the highest rate of female
incarceration in the world so is
fascinating to get to talk to some of
these female prisoners so we'll we'll
take you inside